aktuell trainiert das bundesheer sind
der sonnenschutz und transport am land
und in der luft
200 soldatinnen und soldaten nehmen an
dass lohn mobile protection teil
gestartet wird im langen leben in
niederösterreich die übung erstreckt
sich über den raum melk bis hin zum
truppenübungsplatz allentsteig die übung
läuft bereits seit montag regelt werden
neue szenarien durchgespielt
die liste die schutzwürdigen personen zu
schnell und sicher wie möglich von a
nach b zu transportieren
die luftstreitkräfte setzen dafür zehn
flugzeuge und hubschrauber ein
darunter auch der hubschrauber ab 70
black hawk
ungefähr für die übung seit 2010 ein bis
zweimal jährlich durch luft und
landstreitkräfte können dadurch ihre
zusammenarbeit optimieren und stärken